[Music]
the story of adani is the story of the
world's third richest man being cut down
to size by a short seller group on the
other side of the world
an industrialist who has been favored by
Mr Modi the Danish scandal a wake-up
call to the Indian government that we
need a complete overhaul of our
regulatory system
crony capitalism has developed because
these businessmen play such a key role
in building out infrastructure
the Hindenburg reports through a spanner
in the works
[Music]
on January 24th a report from U.S based
short seller Hindenburg research accused
adani of share price manipulation and
fraud and that ultimately knocked about
100 billion dollars off of their Market
valuation
gauto madani went from being the world's
third richest man on the Forbes rich
list to somewhere in the 20s it was
extraordinary the adani story is a
question of who you know versus What
markets know it's a question of whether
a Donny's connections are strong enough
to carry this massive infrastructure
Empire through the market tomorrow
sparked by a single short report
he has paid back his debt on his
personal shareholding which he had
borrowed about two and a half billion
dollars
nobody in this country has the concern
about the ability to repay debt so
underlying the entire story of adani we
should never forget is a very competent
man and a very competent businessman who
owns fantastic companies with very good
cash flows the fundamentals of our
company are very strong
and we have an impeccable track record
of fulfilling our depth obligations I
think the Hindenburg report raised
really fundamental questions about
investing in India whether you could
trust the corporate governance at listed
companies where you had your shares and
were parking your own money
I think it also raised broader questions
about the Integrity of India's
institutions whether it's the stock
market regulator sebi or the law
enforcement agencies and finally the
Integrity of the business press in India
the extent to which they've been
covering diligently what's happening at
leading groups like adani
like Narendra Modi the prime ministers
from Gujarat he's a first generation
businessman comes from a community of
entrepreneurs he started off running his
own business then over a period of time
got into exports and from then it's been
this almost non-stop expansion well I've
met him in some industry forums he came
across as a very focused entrepreneur is
the man who more than anyone else has
risen both in Fame and reputation uh
during the Modi years there does seem to
be a very very nice parallel between the
rise of Narendra Modi and the rise of
Gotham adani and the rumors that he's
close to them are not new rumors they've
been around for 20 years go to madani
and Narendra Modi have a relationship
that one could describe as symbiotic
adani's rise in business has coincided
with modi's rise in politics first in
Gujarat where Modi was chief minister at
the same time that adani was rising in
business and then from 2014 when Modi
took power as prime minister adani's
rise was if anything even more stellar
he has also focused his interests on
those things that what Mr Modi calls the
new India is also focused on which is a
infrastructure building rapidly trying
to get India up to scale so that it can
compete and on several fronts
Mr adani's interests aligned with that
of the Union government of India
he also has one other thing going for
him and that is you have to remember
that he is playing on the India growth
story India needs a huge investment in
infrastructure and he is positioned
right at the fulcrum
where the finger needs to be put
the dear that put adani on the map was
when he won the rights to operate the
land in Mundra
the port allowed him to demonstrate that
I am a competent businessman regardless
of any connection
which means that it opened up for him
the doors to other deals
I think Mr adani would like the
perception to remain that he is very
close to Mr Modi now how close he is to
Mr body is only a question that Mr Modi
could answer
opposition politicians and a few
Intrepid journalists have also been
raising questions over adani's integrity
and about possible corruption or
cronyism
they don't have much to work on other
than circumstantial ties
I don't have any evidence of this but
they
did these contracts the ports to some
extent but the airports for sure I was
in Delhi and adani had just won the
right to operate six airports all of a
sudden out of the blue the sky was not
known as a airport operator and yet he
just came in and won this massive bid
thank you
yes it does help to be a big
entrepreneur because in relation to land
allotment in local licensing government
steps on the plate but they do it for
everybody I would say that it's worse
than that that in some senses the
allegation has been that the state has
been complicit with what has been going
on with the adani group adani has a
record of winning significant Court
battles in India questions have been
asked in the Press about the role of the
Judiciary in the businessman's rise but
nothing has ever come of these
allegations which have been dismissed by
the company and the government
the Modi government doesn't normally
comment on business stories but it has
pushed back hard on any suggestion that
it has a special relationship with adani
this is
[Music]
adani has been building infrastructure
projects in neighboring countries
including Bangladesh and Sri Lanka and
in many cases these were deals that were
agreed either during or after a
bilateral visit by Modi to one of these
countries in Sri Lanka adani secured a
700 million dollar Container Terminal
project which the government said was
secured with Indian government help
before backing out of that statement
in Israel adani secured the concession
to operate hifa Port which is Israel's
second largest
in Bangladesh after a visit by Modi to
his Bangladeshi counterparts Sheikh
Hasina won a deal for a power project
which involves burning coal in India and
then transmitting power over the border
into Bangladesh
[Music]
it is a structurally important business
for this government for sure because the
government's strategy of national
champions is hinged
on the idea that these companies provide
the backbone that will take India into
the next phase of its growth adani
discontroversy has been able to execute
these ambitious infrastructure projects
and for India to realize its demographic
potential it needs infrastructure it
needs roads it needs airports it needs
energy
and adani has been able to deliver that
if adoni can't do that then who will
strictly speaking the quote-unquote
adani group doesn't exist that's just
the name given to the companies in which
the adani family has majority ownership
and there are a lot of them at the heart
of his conglomerate is adani ports and
special economic zone
adani power is India's largest private
thermal power producer and a Donny
Enterprise
's adani's Mining and coal trading
operations
Dani totalgas is a joint venture with
France's total energies and adoni green
energy is India's largest Renewable
Energy company
adani's other listed companies include
adoni transmission and adani Wilmar and
beyond that the group has a huge range
of operations in sectors like airports
roads and cement so recently the adani
group has been on an absolute tear it's
now India's biggest airport operator and
last year became a media operator as
well after a successful hostile takeover
attempt on NDTV you know the adani
business model is the same business
model that is followed by many promoters
in India it's a business model which
says we get into those Industries where
there's a regulatory framework where the
government matters where the politician
who's in charge of the government
matters this is not new to India you've
always had business houses that have
flourished by being very close to
governments and have taken a new
advantage of this proximity he has also
put his money where most people have
been reticent to do so
infrastructure is low return long
gestation business and there are not too
many people who are focused on it with
the kind of laser-like sharpness that he
has been
many avatani's listed companies had seen
their share prices rocket in recent
years to levels more typical of a
fast-growing Tech startup rather than
say industrial outfits or utilities
providers
before the Hindenburg report they were
clearly overvalued compared to
equivalent companies in their sectors
clearly valuations that out of the
ordinary wood on their own probably have
been sufficient for Hindenburg to want
to take a closer look
I started to look into him and it was
incredible because it seemed that even
though he was growing so fast and the
share price of his companies were
skyrocketing and he was obviously
playing such an important role for the
government and yet no one seemed to be
writing about him or notice him I was
repeatedly struck by how reluctant
Brokers analysts were about going public
with their doubts about these companies
valuations when in private they could be
scathing but the higher shares went the
more hesitant they became
the belief in adani came down to two
things one The Narrative of India's
Breakneck growth and his alleged
connections with Modi and for a great
many investors that was enough to
overpower any questions about the
group's financials journalists and
investors were starting to ask some
questions about the evaluations there
were also questions about a Donny's
extensive use of offshore vehicles and
of the the presence in its shareholder
base of a lot of investors that were
funds that appeared to be only Holding
adani stock but nobody could quite put
it all together
and in part this was because adani has a
track record of going after critics of
taking legal action against journalists
the last 20
20 kind for the freedom of press in
India and one of the reasons they have
not been very kind is like in other
parts of the world more and more of the
press is now being controlled by
billionaires who own these press
vehicles and the reason they like to own
this press Vehicles is firstly they make
sure that any criticism of them and
their businesses is a muted secondly
it's a way to carry favor with
politicians
foreign
it was a Friday I had just been to a
work lunch and I get a text from a
contact saying we have something that we
think will be of interest to you do you
want to take a look so I checked the the
report and of course the first thing
that you see is how the world's third
richest man is perpetuating the biggest
Con in corporate history as a reporter
as anyone that sort of grabs your
attention there are two main allegations
made by Hindenburg one of which is stock
market manipulation and the other one is
accounting fraud there were all these
offshore entities a lot of which were
registered in jurisdictions like
Mauritius or Singapore which only seem
to invest in adani shares the Hindenburg
report came out of nowhere it stunned
the markets the business community and
India's political class what Hindenburg
did that was so effective was to bring
all the facts all the rumors all the
circumstantial evidence together in one
place and turn it into a narrative that
was credible
one of adani's senior Executives came
out with a video that hit back
aggressively at hindenburg's claims the
report is a malicious combination of
selective misinformation stale baseless
and discredited allegations that have
been tested and rejected by India's
highest courts adani came out with a 413
page rebuttal which was quite
extraordinary what struck us at the Ft
was the rhetoric that was used in it
they called the report a calculated
attack on India
which seems like a strange language for
a company to be using and is more
reminiscent of the kind of rhetoric that
you hear from India's government
the report also and outcry in Parliament
one of the loudest voices was mahua
moycha a former Banker from the trinimal
congress party
she had been urging the market regulator
to investigate adani's alleged Market
manipulation
some of the issues you raised were
issues that I had raised were issues
that other people had raised over the
last three or four years
and some of what Hindenburg pointed out
was just common sense and logical at one
point Raul Gandhi who's the most
prominent figure in the opposition
congress party stood up and gave a
speech questioning all of adani's
foreign deals he also held up pictures
showing adani and Modi sitting together
on adani's jet it's very telling that
all of his remarks in the speech
relating to alleged ties between adani
and the Prime Minister were expunged
from the Parliamentary record
all this is to distract from the Panic
that the prime minister is feeling
that his relationship with Mr Irani is
going to be exposed Gandhi was convicted
of defamation in a Modi related case in
Gujarat in March and then expelled from
Parliament just a year before the next
election in a move that his congress
party have described as tit-for-tat
retaliation against his public remarks
about the Prime Minister and the
billionaire because this government
functions with the level of opacity
which is not normal for most democracies
and certainly doesn't pass the smell
test I think the opposition was always
aware of just how
this government was helping its friends
and their allies but given that the BJP
government came to power in India on an
anti-crony capitalism Wicket for them to
be embroiled in a scandal that was so
obviously chronic capitalistic and that
too for just one man you think that's
all the ingredients were in for this
very
um you know exciting political Financial
portfolio
I just remember checking in at the open
day after day just watching the market
value of these companies evaporate
Indian promoters have been very good
at managing the regulatory environment
as a group so that short selling in
India is not a frequent occurrence
it's not that it's impossible to short
shares or to short companies in India
it's that it's almost impossible to make
money from it you have to do it through
other jurisdictions the one that is most
used is probably Singapore
Hindenburg could have bet against Dani
through India's main stock index the
Nifty 50. in which adani companies are
constituents
it would have been able to use a
derivative called the single stock
future that would allow the fam to have
a weighted exposure to the group through
the Singapore Exchange
to do this it would need singapore-based
Banks to access counterparties they
would offer Security based on the whole
index with exposure to India's 50
leading stocks but then sell most of the
underlying shares leaving just adani
companies
that means hinderberg could have exposed
to adani and short distributive like a
normal security only crucially it could
do it in Singapore and therefore avoid
India's disclosure rules that makes
shooting hard
the timing of the report was pretty much
perfect as far as Hindenburg was
concerned it was a surgical strike the
impact was to torpedo shares in adani
companies just as it was trying to get
this massive share sale out the door in
January 2023 adani Enterprises launched
a share offering with the aim of raising
two and a half billion dollars they
ultimately decided to cool it off that
was I think a huge win for Hindenburg if
he had managed to pull off that share
offering it would have been a sliding
doors moment but instead it went
seriously wrong
and some people say because he's a short
seller you should not trust him I said
because he's a short seller I trust him
more why they are putting their money
where their mouth is there are three key
elements to adani's finances and why
Hindenburg was interested in the company
Share Price Corporate governance and
debt levels you had a Donnie and his
family officially holding the majority
of his stock in some cases right at the
75 percent limit allowed under Indian
Securities Law but you also had these
offshore entities owning a Donnie shares
and these offshore entities allegedly
have links to the adani family
that raises two immediate problems one
does adani have a sufficient free float
and two is there round tripping is there
Market manipulation that is impacting
the share price both of these could be a
violation of Indian law
so this is something I flagged way back
in 2019 I wrote to the Securities and
Exchange Board of India I wrote to the
ministry of fine Minister of Finance and
I got absolutely no answers
probably what is so distinctive about
adani is not that he engaged in these
practices that's normal in India for
most promoters but that he did it to
this level where the free float was so
small where his own ownership of the
stock was so high
in an interim report released in May a
panel asked by the Supreme Court to look
into potential regulatory failure
relating to adani said that sebby had
hit a wall in its investigation but it
said the regulator had found no evidence
of share price manipulation
and with no indication that the
authorities are going to find a Smoking
Gun of any kind that might back up
hindenburg's allegations the share
prices of adani's listed companies have
started to rise again
the company has also taken steps to
improve its opaque financing and
corporate structure the promoters have
paid off a significant amount of the
shareback debt criticized by Hindenburg
and brought in new investors to reduce
the share of adani companies under
family control
florida-based gqg invested almost 2
billion dollars in March and has since
increased its investment
two further listings are planned at
adani companies worth billions
a cleaner balance sheet and new Equity
financing has gone some way to reassure
Banks bondholders and investors that the
company is fundamentally sound if you
look back 25 30 years in every country
you find very aggressive entrepreneurs
coming borrowing money growing Empires
and many of them make mistakes they
don't build solid businesses and then
the market turns we see them coming down
is happened in India will happen again
the key point is we must distinguish
between the stock price for all these
people and the businesses but convincing
Skeptics and political opponents is
going to be a much tougher task
tadani's story has revealed a lot about
Indian democracy because democracy is
not just living in a free country it's
living in a country where the pillars of
democracy all work together the image of
India and Indian business has definitely
taken a slight hit with the adani group
no doubt about that having said that
because the India grows story is so
strong it has now become a Muslim market
for every company in the world I think
it's probably too early to say whether
this story of the short seller versus
the billionaire is something that has
transformed Indian business or that we
will have forgotten about in a year's
time
the issue is about the concentration of
wealth and whether or not India's middle
class will rise up with the success of
these businessmen is it going to be like
in South Korea where the chable helped
lay the foundation for the economy or is
it going to be like Russia where the
wealth stayed in the hands of a very few
oligarchs at the expense of the nation
thank you